[Music]
everyone seems to know everything about
everything these days I don't mean that
people just seem to have an opinion on
any given topic which of course is great
and that's what free speech is all about
instead what I'm talking about here is
the constant and endless stream of
people pretending that they know exactly
how to run the world if only everyone
would listen to them the Iran nuclear
deal well that animate Twitter Fox knows
all about enriched uranium how to
destroy Isis your unemployed cousin
knows exactly how to demolish them the
best way to administer health care your
mom's friend on Facebook who can't
figure out unlock her iPad has finally
figured out how to make single-payer
work this constant expression of fake
knowledge is partly a function of social
media which rewards us for quick hits
and maximum snark but it's also a
function of something that's been built
into us since our beginning the human
ego ego is constantly rewarded in this
crazy world we live in do you think the
rise of Trump might have had a little
something to do with ego clearly Trump
understands the way we all connect to a
powerful personality and he uses that
power in every interaction that he has
be it via speech meeting or on Twitter
but beneath this connection seems to be
the fragile ego of a child who must lash
out any time they hear anything not to
their liking by the way I don't think a
politician using the persuasive power of
personality is something new as far as
the presidency is concerned while Trump
is a particularly interesting case of
ego in the White House let's not pretend
that Barack Obama with his promises of
hoping change didn't have one as well or
Bill Clinton who is a master at making
every person in the room feel like they
were the only person that he cared about
while there isn't a direct comparison to
the charm of Obama and Clinton to the
alpha-male tactics of Trump there is an
interesting through line to what types
of people we respond to interestingly
I'm not sure that you could say that
George W Bush falls into this strong ego
bucket like W or not there was a
humbleness perhaps born of insecurity
that he had that I think the others
lacked of course W had his own set of
problems but that's the whole other
story now let me back up here
second I don't think that having an ego
is bad after all
each of us has an ego in some way by
definition an ego is a person's sense of
self-esteem or self-importance of course
having a sense of self-esteem and
self-importance is good overall nobody
wants to be walking around feeling
worthless or irrelevant feeling
worthless isn't healthy for you and it's
not great for anyone around you either
of course on the other hand an inflated
sense of importance can be dangerous to
here's where I have to be careful many
of the brightest minds in arts sports
politics science and virtually every
other field have an inflated sense of
self importance and this trait is partly
what helps them in achieving greatness I
think it's fair to say but the
astronomical success of people like
Steve Jobs Michael Jordan and Beyonce
all have a little something to do with
their sense of self-importance driven by
an inflated self-esteem the endless
dedication the hard work and the
sacrifice that it takes to be a leader
in your field can often be borne out of
ego to pretend this doesn't exist in the
people we love and admire or that is
somehow exclusively a bad thing would be
to deny them something very human and by
the way I won't be presumptuous enough
to think that I don't have an ego myself
after all I talk on camera for a living
the ego that we all have to bear ease
degrees is partly what's causing such a
disconnect in our conversations right
now we judge too quickly we jump to
conclusions without evidence and we
condemn too fast all somehow guys as a
way of showing how smart and how correct
we are I for one have no problem telling
you I don't have all the answers I think
you guys know most of my opinions on the
big issues and I love sharing them with
you as my opinions change evolve or
strengthen but on major complex issues
like the Iran deal or healthcare or
abortion or gun control I don't pretend
to have every answer do you think that
most of the so-called experts who
pontificate on everything actually read
the full text of the Iran deal I doubt
that most of them did
how many experts are even congressmen
who wrote it actually fully read
Obamacare or the Republican replacement
I'm guessing some did but it's probably
a very small my
irony instead of doing the rigorous work
to figure out what's best they instead
pretend to know everything and make us
feel as if only we would listen to them
that we'd have a perfect society this is
silly lazy thinking of course our
mainstream news which doles out suppose
it important conversations and five
minute clips with eight different guests
all talking over each other at once
really isn't helping the situation and
on the broader issues like abortion or
gun control pretending that you know
exactly how the law should be so that
everything will work out just right for
society is equally as nonsensical we
live in a pluralistic society and the
human factor the simple fact that we're
all individuals is proof that nothing
will ever be perfect for all of us what
we can do is limit the amount of control
we have over each other while at the
same time respecting others beliefs and
the same right to property and happiness
that we want others to afford to us most
of us want sensible answers and being
real with ourselves is the only way
we're going to get there saying I don't
know or I haven't decided or I need more
information
shouldn't be seen as a weakness it
should be seen as a strength oh and by
the way of course I'm guilty of
sometimes jumping to conclusions and
judging before I have the proper
information and again I have an ego too
one by the way which you often help me
keep in check but I will never pretend
that I have all the answers and if I
ever do I have no doubt that you find
folks will let me know in the comments
right down below
[Music]
you